hello everyone and thank you for joining
us a for this session this is ops 302
will be covering monitoring this code
I'm honored to have PUD Sandhu from the
Schlumberger us are a team here with us
today later in the session he'll be
discussing how his team and others are
slumbered implemented the practice of
monitoring code he'll also give it to
some lessons that they have learned in
this journey that we think we can
benefit from as you start yours pod
thank you so much for being here today
thank you your ISA pleasure to be here
my name is Yuri Greenstein and I'm a
site reliability engineer at Google
cloud on the customer reliability
engineering team so here are the topics
we'll be covering today we'll start with
understanding the basics well define the
concept of soil as it relates to the
practices of SCI reliability engineering
from there we'll cover the objection
objectives of ask code practices
next we'll review the specific rule
cloud monitoring entities that can be
automated and compare three approaches
to automating them I'll wrap up the
first portion of the session by showing
you cola specific examples of automating
cloud monitoring entities from there
I'll hand it over to pod to cover the
lessons learned at Schlumberger as you
know that pursue this in earnest let's
get started so first what do we mean by
toil and what is automation important
well if we go back to our fundamental
principles and practices what we call
that site reliability engineering or SRE
is a specific set of practices developed
at Google and since embraced everywhere
that hold user happiness and appropriate
reliability at scale as their ultimate
objectives what are the major areas of
focus for both the more generalized
DevOps movement and sre to the specific
implementation of it
there's the focus on automating as much
of the repetitive manual tasks that
specifically don't add enduring value as
possible ultimately our objective is to
achieve the appropriate level of
reliability for our services and
maintain that level even though as user
demand and load increases you know
without having to proportionally scale
the staff required to support that
service this is really the ultimate
value of focusing automation it allows
us to reach much greater levels of scale
this is a fourth already simplified
version of the answer you can find much
more detail on why we focus on reducing
toil and the books were published in the
top
I'll particularly encourage you to
review chapter 5 of the first sre book
golf eliminating toil which discusses
this in much greater detail so now that
we've covered the value of automation
let's talk about what we mean when we
say that we want to treat something as
code here are the things we'll be
looking to accomplish now a lot of this
comes from the infrastructure as code
principles but there's no reason why we
can't think of monitoring this code
using the same exact language so first
we want to be able to accurately
determine if there are any differences
between what we want to be the key to
our monitoring configuration and what is
actually currently the case and so to
that end when you go way to precisely
specify the desired state and be able to
retrieve the current state yeah next we
want our work to be able usable we want
to be able to create modules and
components that other folks keep used
and again we're in pursuit of scale here
and that can't happen if every service
key must have build this from scratch
especially the model where certainly is
a shared service across multiple service
teams we want to use a declarative
approach to specifying our desired state
this means we want to define the state
we want not the set of actions to take
to get there now one of the benefits of
this approach is that it's item a which
means that we can run our automation no
matter what the current state is and
still be sure we'll arrive at the
correct end State
this is different than imperative
approach where we specify the exact
steps that she could taken that might
work best for programming but not for
configuration and finally in part
because we are sorry so value of
software engineering practices we're
going to treat these configurations in
the same way we treat other source code
one important thing we want to achieve
is the other side of the reusability
coin we're going to both share our work
and enable others to collaborate and
contribute to it and this is what code
management is incredibly important so I
hope that you are now convinced of the
value of automation in general and
applying as code principles to
configurations specifically at this
point
the next logical question is okay how
should we get started what kill me
actually automate so in Google Cloud
monitoring there are four primary
entities whose creation updates and
deletions can be automated the first
three are available today and that's
where most of our focus will be they are
up ten checks so this is a feature of
cloud monitoring that allows you to
configure synthetic 10 entire synthetic
checks to validate things like URL
availability website performance and TCP
connectivity on VMs alerting policies so
I'll give in to their d-doesn't in bit
but these are how you can feel your
cloud of modern transactions send alerts
and notifications when specific
conditions are met and finally
dashboards are collections of chars
folks used to visualize the state of
health of their systems when looking to
automate Google Cloud monitoring
configurations you have three primary
options the first option is to use
either the Google cloud API directly or
make API calls in your code using client
libraries provided by Google or third
parties this works very well if you
debar if you have a robust software
engineering practice and you need to
include monitoring automation and larger
scripting our automation projects your
second option is to use Google cloud
deployment management this is a fully
management hosted service provided by
Google it uses gamal as this declaration
language and the current state of your
configuration once you apply is then
stored it in the cloud you can interact
with deployment manager using Chicana
commands or its own API and then your
third option and duong I'll be using
fire examples coming up next is
terraform this is an open source toolkit
provided by Hagi core
it uses its own language for
declarations but it has an excellent
multi-cloud support which is important
for many users the open source version
which is what I'll be showing you today
store state locally in TF state funds so
these can be checked into source control
just like the main configuration files
so I imagine by now this is probably
enough theory for everyone let's get
into some specific examples let's start
with a simple example of creating an app
engine as you may recall I've done
checks are used to measure web service
or a TCP endpoint availability on lines
here's what our terraform file looks
like there are five things to note here
first at the very top
specify the provider to litera from know
that we're working to cloud and to
provide the project or operating it next
we define the resource it's an outline
check in the HTTP our check section we
specify the path and port to connect on
and whether or not to use as a cell in
the monitored resource section we
specify there were four checking a URL
rather than a TCP endpoint the post we
want to connect to and the project where
this attention will be created and
finally we specify a Content mastering
we want to validate in the response in
the terminal we run the terraform plan
command it'll validate our configuration
compared against the current state if
there isn't any and determine what
resources need to be updated here the
plan is to add one new resource as you
can see in the output at the bottom once
we confirm that the plan is correct we
issue the terraform applying command it
will once again provide the plan and ask
for an explicit confirmation it will
then provide the specific resources that
were created changed or deleted as a
result and there we are we can now log
into the cloud console and validate that
our off time check has been created if
we want to clean up what we did we can
issue the terraform and destroy command
similarly if you apply it will create
and validate the plan of action it'll
then ask us for confirmation before
actually destroying a resource and then
let us know when it's done and now we're
back to a clean slate
let's do could take a look at another
slightly more complex example when once
we created an on-time check we may want
to get alerts even when it fails before
we get into the code unless we do the
basics want to create an alerting policy
which combines both the condition to be
evaluated to true the notifications and
the mechanism to be used for the
notification that sound called a
notification channel our terraform code
needs to describe both of these so
here's how we would configure the policy
in the UI rule to use l10 check URL is
the resource and they check past as
metric mu then filter it to just to
check we care about we would use to
count false aggregator to count how many
of the locations from which to check is
recovering report failures our condition
within trigger if any failures are
reported within 5 minutes
here's how we would write terraform file
to represent that note that we specify
the notification channel first with type
email and an email address with a
Larssen go to the output madenda is
stored in the variable we then define
our actual alert policy with a condition
threshold there we provide the metric
filter the comparison operator in the
congregation's and then finally we
specify the notification the
notification channel we've created up at
the top using the variable all the way
to bar when we run terraform plan we see
that it's actually going to create two
resources the notification channel and
the alerting policy is going to use that
channel what we want apply we see that
two resources are created as we expect
as before we can confirm that our
learning policy was created in a console
we can also confirm that the correct
notification channel was created and
their policy is used if we want to undo
what we've done we can begin issue the
terraform destroy commit note this time
two resources are destroying terraform
is aware of the dependencies involved
and destroys the alerting policy for
erst
and then removes the notification
channel I hope this served as a good
introduction to the practice of
monitoring his code and how to use
terraform to automate configuring google
cloud monitoring for your projects at
this point I'll turn over to pod to talk
about how the SRD team at slumber here
put these into real-world practice Thank
You REE so I'm going to talk to you
about slumber shades one Crisco journey
over the past two years starting with
2018 in Schlumberger there are many
solution teams developing apps and
services for the Delphi ecosystem and
each one of these teams was creating
their own version of the monitoring
framework what I mean is they were
creating dashboards or alerts or even
log based metrics in their own silos
using different coding languages well in
some cases just configuring through the
UI in terms of the big picture
it was obviously great to see so many
teams taking monitoring so seriously but
the problem was with this approach that
very little code was being reused which
led to being hard to build any best
practices or learnings
and in most cases word-of-mouth or
presentations were the only way of
showing what each of the teams were
doing so what changed in 2019 well a new
central asari team was created and it's
the team that I working today the
purpose of this team is to provide
governance and alignment across the
various solution teams in Schlumberger
at the beginning of 2019 we started
brainstorming of what we kind of wanted
to focus on for that year and after
reading various books on sre from Google
we decided it should be toil management
after attending many presentations and
demos of each the monitoring frameworks
from each of the teams we wanted to
merge the implementation learnings into
one toolkit so the idea of creating one
toolkit or one framework we believe may
allow us to add new monitoring
capabilities that would benefit all the
teams using it one example of this was
when Google introduced the service
service level monitoring API so last
year we could also ramp up neutral
solution teams much faster with the use
of this toolkit within their apps or
services and by using the one toolkit we
could spread the message of how we
wanted to monitor systems of Crossland
machine more consistently so the fun
part creating the toolkit so what did we
do by taking the best bits of each of
the solutions monitoring scripts we
created a toolkit to work with the
Google monitoring endpoints key to the
design of the toolkit was to understand
that most teams already had one Turing
setup either through the code or through
the UI and we want to take the approach
of backing up and restoring backing up
the aspects of monitoring that they care
about in form of JSON files using
protobuf and providing the ability to
restore from them
once we created the toolkit we needed a
way of teams to adopt it there's no
point having a toolkit that no one uses
so we created a second git repo which
they could fork from to get started and
both these git repos are an image in
this slide
we win the get repo we provided the
necessary pipelines to take our approach
or backing up and restoring we also
provided the monitoring controls that
will need to be in place for all of our
GC piece for Sauk to compliance and we
also included other examples of how to
monitor different Google cloud
technologies such as pub/sub Google
Storage datastore Google load balancer
and for the teams that are new to SMB
practices we also included examples of
how to set up SL eyes and SL O's within
the get repoed that the solution teams
had forked they could also add their
monitoring configuration that was
specific to their app we inner source
both of these get reposts so that teams
could contribute new features fix bugs
or even provide good examples of
monitoring certain aspects which the
other teams may benefit from each of
these git repos are managed through pull
requests which our team approve because
we have the broad knowledge of how all
the other teams are using this that will
give and we can give a device in the
best ways of monitoring certain aspects
of Google cloud having everyone on the
same talk it gives us the agility to be
more dynamic with either new technology
adoption or compliance requirements so
what do the key takeaways from our
learning of our implementation I would
ask you to go and look at the Google git
repo and github there you would find
examples of how to backup your alerts
using Python and I think this would give
you ideas of how to add monitoring as
code into your organization's so where
are we today we believe that within your
organization's you can start by
implementing the following points that
are shown in this light and within our
organization by consolidating into a
single toolkit or framework I'm going to
explain to you how we are benefited by
doing this
number one new solution teams are no
longer reinventing the wheel
the learning curve is less steep and the
time spent is significantly reduce
implementing monitoring no.2 monitoring
is no longer an afterthought the
automated deployment allows the solution
teams to implement monitoring early in
their product life cycle enabling them
to have insights into the reliability
and performance of the critical user
journeys and metrics are bait to find in
their projects this will also improve
the solutions overrules reliability at
the time of launch number three
continuity and continuous improvement is
achieved using code rather than having
to update multiple different
documentation sources and lastly point
number four the central support
organization has a consistent interface
for monitoring alerting and reporting
across the various solution teams both
for operational and business level needs
this is an example of our service level
objectives compliance dashboard that we
created in-house this gives us a single
pane of glass for both business and
solution teams on how well our apps and
services are performing each of the
colored boxes represents where a
solution or shared service is either in
compliant non-compliant or possibly even
in feature freeze and with that I like
to thank you too for listening to me
today and I hand it over to URI I thank
you very much for that excu informative
I really appreciate you being here today
and thank you to everyone for watching
we hope that we find this useful and we
certainly would encourage you to get
started with your own journey toward
monitoring us code thanks again
take care